pero widing dijo que aunque no confía en
el talibán pues trabajará con ellos para
poder evacuar la mayor cantidad de
estadounidenses de afganistán ha
evacuado a eeuu ya 4.500
estadounidenses faltan 1500 por evacuar
y precisamente en esta alianza de alguna
manera forzada con los talibanes pues se
comprometieron a tratar de agrandar el
perímetro del aeropuerto para evitar que
posibles terroristas lleguen a el
perímetro cercano al aeropuerto también
se comprometieron a no dejar pasar
cargos potenciales carros bombas en los
puntos de control lo que dijo valle es
que no está seguro que pueda asegurarle
a la cantidad de afganos aliados un
retorno a eeuu o algún país refugiado
porque pues simplemente le quedan muy
pocos días y pues parece carecer de
recursos cristóbal pero qué tan viable
es que eeuu tome represalias contra el
estado islámico según aseguró valdés
después de la retirada de las tropas
claro alguien dijo que iba a hacer pagar
a los responsables y que ya di ya tiene
algunos nombres dijo aunque no quiso
obviamente compartirlos pero pues él
dijo que aunque eeuu no esté presente en
afganistán pues tiene la capacidad de
terroristas para atacar desde otros
lugares sobre todo con drones como ya lo
ha mencionado el penta no con los de
hecho acordémonos que pues osama bin
laden fue precisamente
asesinado con drones desde pakistán a
pesar de que eeuu hermano invidente e
invadiendo afganistán